se a efe una función de valores reales
definida en el intervalo cero infinito
es decir está definida en para todos los
x que sean más grandes que 0 y que no
sean 0 verdad cuando decimos cuando
tenemos aquí un paréntesis no estamos
incluyendo el 0 y decimos que nos vamos
hasta infinito y tampoco lo incluimos
verdad dada y la función está dada por
fx igual a logaritmo natural de x más la
integral de 0 a x de la raíz cuadrada de
1 + seno de t de t aunque es decir la
integral la estamos integrando respecto
de cuáles de las siguientes afirmaciones
son verdaderas esto nos está diciendo
que quizás puede haber más de una así
que hay que tener cuidado primer inciso
la segunda derivada de f existe para
todo x mayor que 0 inciso b la primera
derivada de f existe para todo x mayor
que 0 y además es continua en 0 infinito
es decir para todos los puntos mayores
que 0 pero no es diferenciable en 0
infinito
bueno tenemos otras dos otras dos otros
dos incisos así que vamos a ir
trabajando uno a uno y para ello voy a
empezar reescribiendo la función ok
entonces tenemos fx fx esta es igual al
logaritmo natural de x más la integral
de 0 a x de la raíz cuadrada de 1 + el
seno de t
dt muy bien y esto parece ser esté
bastante atemorizante pero realmente es
muy sencillo de trabajar muy bien
entonces primero vamos a ver qué pasa
con su segunda derivada y para ello pues
tenemos que derivar al menos una primera
vez vamos a derivar una vez y quien
sería la primera derivada de f la
derivada del logaritmo natural es 1 / x
as la derivada de una integral aquí
tenemos que utilizar el famoso teorema
fundamental del cálculo que nos dice que
si derivamos esta expresión simplemente
nos queda
el integrando evaluado en x
esto sería uno más el seno de xy esta es
nuestra primera derivada vamos a ver
quién sería la segunda derivada la verde
amos la segunda derivada la segunda
derivada de f
sería derivar 1 entre x que derivar una
entre x es como perdón derivar x a la
menos 1 verdad y x derivar x a la menos
1 sería como poner menos uno entre x
cuadrada es decir la derivada de x a la
menos 1 es menos x a la menos 2 verdad
que es exactamente esto y luego sumamos
la derivada la persona derivada de esta
raíz y la derivada de la raíz bueno
la derivada de la raíz de x por ejemplo
es uno entre dos veces la raíz de x y
como aquí vamos a tener que usar regla
de la cadena esto es uno entre dos veces
la raíz de lo que hay adentro que es uno
más
seno de equis y ahora por regla de la
cadena hay que multiplicar por la
derivada de uno más seno de x y esa
derivada es simplemente la derivada del
seno de x que es coseno de x así que
quitamos este uno y dejamos simplemente
el coseno de x y aquí ya tenemos nuestra
segunda derivada muy bien entonces lo
único que tenemos que fijarnos es para
qué valores esto está definido y para
cuáles no y no tenemos que aquí el
primer sumando que es menos uno entre x
cuadrada el único lugar donde no está
definido es en cero verdad porque yo no
puedo dividir entre cero sin embargo sin
embargo no estamos incluyendo el cero y
eso fue lo que dijimos al inicio porque
tenemos el intervalo cero infinito
abierto es decir él
no lo vamos a considerar muy bien
entonces ahí no hay problema el problema
sería cuando dos veces la raíz de uno
más seno de x se haga cero es decir que
pasa o para qué valores se tiene que uno
más el seno de x es igual a cero o en
otras palabras para que valores de x
tenemos que el seno de x es menos uno
menos 1 y acordémonos muy bien de esto
tenemos por ejemplo
el seno lo podemos ver representado en
el círculo unitario por supuesto eso no
es un círculo
y eso parece un poco más un círculo y el
seno
el seno lo podemos ver como que a cada
ángulo x verdad si tenemos un ángulo x
el seno será justamente esta altura muy
bien por supuesto queremos ver para qué
valores de x tenemos esta altura quien
menos uno ok entonces el valor de x
tiene que ser este ángulo de 270 grados
pero como estamos trabajando en radiales
en realidad estamos hablando de que para
x x igual a tres medios verdad 3 y
medios y medio son 90 grados entonces
aquí son tres veces 90 grados muy bien
para este valor en particular digo hay
muchísimos más como por ejemplo si le
damos otra vuelta y otra vuelta y otra
vuelta verdad tenemos muchos otros
valores para los cuales esto no no está
definido pero con uno me basta porque
nada más me preguntaban si existe para
todo x mayor que cero y aquí vimos uno
que no entonces podemos concluir gracias
a este numerito que la segunda derivada
no está definida
está definida
x igual a tres y medio si eso es porque
el denominador se anula y eso no puede
ser porque no podemos dividir entre cero
muy bien entonces vamos a repasar qué es
lo que tenemos para nuestras preguntas
que nos hicieron nos preguntan la
segunda derivada existe para todo x
mayor que cero bueno ya vimos que eso no
es cierto verdad al menos entre sí
medios no está definida entonces esa no
es cierta la segunda nos dice la primera
derivada existe para todo x mayor que 0
pues sí sí verdad aquí el único problema
que tenemos es cuando x es cero pero
pero a nosotros no nos importa el punto
cero nos preguntan también que si además
la primera derivada es continua en cero
infinito y si verdad porque éste es
continua y ésta también es continua
entonces suma de funciones continuas
pues escondimos ahora bien
esto nos dice que no sea diferenciable
en 0 como infinito eso es cierto verdad
quién sería la derivada de nuestra
primera derivada pues la derivada de la
derivada es la segunda derivada y en
efecto dijimos que no está definida en
tres primeros quiere decir que no es
diferenciable en al menos un punto
entonces si no es derivable en al menos
un punto no lo es derivada no es
derivable en todo el intervalo verdad
así que ésta sí es cierta bueno al menos
ya tenemos una cierta siguiente este es
un poquito más elaborado nos preguntan
si existe un número alfa mayor que uno
tal que el valor absoluto de la derivada
es menor o igual que el valor absoluto
de la función para todo x para todos
ahí estaba el antivirus para todo x
mayor que alfa muy bien
eso es lo que nos preguntan vamos a ver
si esto es cierto
un poco
esencialmente lo que me están
preguntando es si puede encontrar un
número tal que a partir de ese momento
la derivada sea más chica que la función
y vamos a explorar un poco por lo
siguiente tenemos que para para obama no
sé digo tenemos aquí un logaritmo
natural entonces tenemos que jugar con
lo que conocemos por ejemplo qué pasa
y si x es más grande que él
aunque hay que pasa si x es más grande
que como sería el logaritmo natural de x
bueno el logaritmo natural de x
recordemos que es una gráfica algo así
algo así verdad entonces si aquí tengo
entonces para valores más grandes que el
logaritmo natural va a ser más grande
que el logaritmo natural de verdad es
mayor que el logaritmo natural de que es
uno muy bien eso es porque la función es
creciente vamos a quedarnos con esto
nada más y ahora veamos qué es lo que
podemos sacar también podemos sacar que
uno entre x es bueno hagámoslo de esta
forma
si yo paso dividiendo la tengo x / e es
mayor que 1 verdad si lo paso dividiendo
y luego voy a pasar dividiendo la x
entonces ya no va a estar aquí ahora
vamos a pasarla dividiendo aquí y
entonces tenemos que uno entre x es más
chico que 1 / 01 / x perdón 1 / es más
chico que 1 verdad porque porque es más
grande que uno esto implica que 1 entre
1 es más grande que uno entre pero 1
entre 1 es 1 así que tenemos esto
entonces fijémonos que uno es más grande
que uno entre y esto es más grande que
uno entre x así que tenemos esta
cadenita de desigualdades donde vemos
que el logaritmo al final de cuentas
olvídense de todo esto que hay en medio
el logaritmo natural fue mayor que uno
entre x y justamente es lo que tenemos
de este lado el logaritmo natural de x
1 / x vamos a llamarle a esta hdx este
es hdx y resulta que hdx fue más grande
que su derivada verdad para x más grande
que muy bien entonces ahora vamos a ver
qué pasa con la siguiente función es
decir ahora nos consideramos ésta
le vamos a llamar no se esté
vamos a llamarle
a ésta
gx y está por supuesto es la derivada de
g
bien este es que prima de equis y vamos
a hacer el dibujo de como es esta
función para que nos vemos bien idea de
qué es lo que está pasando que íbamos a
a pintar unos ejes voy siempre tengo
problemas con pintar lo derecho yo creo
que con eso es suficiente
y ahí lo tienen dos ejes muy bien ahora
si me salieron entonces si nos fijamos
en esta forma en esta función voy a
fijarme en que prima voy a dibujar la
gráfica de ge prima la raíz de uno más
seno de x cuánto valen cero en cero
estamos hablando de que el seno de cero
es cero y por lo tanto aquí estamos
parados en uno vamos a movernos al
siguiente punto interesante que es y
medios el seno de pi medios es 1 verdad
y entonces uno más uno es dos y tenemos
la raíz de dos
aquí estará la raíz de 2 y esto es lo
que vale aquí que pasa en 3 y medios
perdón antes de 3 y medios tenemos pi pi
verdad seno de pi es cero entonces
tenemos 101 y la raíz de eso es 1
ahí lo tienen y ahora qué pasa en tres
medios en tres medios el seno de tres y
medios quedamos que era menos uno más
uno nos da cero y si sacamos la raíz de
cero pues es otra vez cero verdad y
finalmente no se vámonos a dos en dos y
esto vale seno de dos pies cero entonces
uno más cero es uno y la raíz de eso es
así que con esto a grandes rasgos
podemos dibujar más o menos la gráfica
de la función verdad más o menos hace
algo así ok yo sé que no fue el mejor
dibujo que he hecho en mi historia pero
en él se entiende bien qué es lo que
está pasando muy bien ahora bien esta es
la gráfica de g prima de x ahora cuál
cuál sería que es que representa la
integral de 0 a x de 1 + seno de t
entonces nos tomamos una x cualquiera
digamos esta x ok y lo que nos está
calculando la integral ya sabemos que es
el área debajo de la curva entonces para
esta x particular me está midiendo
cuánta área hay acumulada hasta este
punto muy bien entonces ya con esto
podemos notar algo muy interesante si
nosotros vamos extendiendo la x en
adelante pues vamos cubriendo más área y
más área y como esta gráfica nunca pasa
del eje de hecho aquí debería verse así
como nunca pasamos por debajo de él
pues gx va acumulando más y más y más y
más área entonces gdx no está acotada no
está acotada es decir que siempre
podemos acumular mucha área mucha área
porque no está acotada cuando x tiende a
infinito muy bien sin embargo que prima
de x que es esta curva si está acotada
tiene un valor máximo y se llama raíz de
2 entonces el máximo de esta función
para los valores este que estén entre 0
e infinito verdad son los que nos
interesan entonces el máximo de la
derivada es exactamente la raíz de dos
así que esto ya nos está diciendo mucho
porque la derivada siempre va a estar
por debajo de raíz de 2 y la función que
siempre puede crecer tanto como uno
quiera verdad no está acotada por
ejemplo por por decir un número que es y
se va a cumplir pues pero por decir un
número para x más grande que 10 la
derivada de geba va a ser más chica que
g ok
y bueno en particular tenemos que cómo
va a ser hdx con respecto a su derivada
bueno como x es más grande que 10 en
particular es más grande que entonces ya
dijimos que la h
va a ser más grande
va a ser más grande que su derivada
justo fue lo que vimos anteriormente y
esto se va a cumplir para las x más
grandes que 10 ahora qué pasa para la g
la gtx también quedamos kg de x va a ser
más grande que su derivada otra vez que
crece tanto como quiera pero la derivada
no entonces va a ocurrir esto y por
consecuencia f x que es hd x + gdx
verdad así así está definida así está
definida acá arriba es h + g
entonces h más g es más grande como h es
más grande que su derivada y g es más
grande que su derivada pues entonces la
suma es más grande que esto verdad que
justamente esto es la derivada de f
entonces para la alfa que tenemos que
tomar es 10 porque para partir de 10 la
función es más grande que su derivada o
lo que es lo mismo la derivada la
derivada es más chica o igual que la
función muy bien y el último punto es
muy directo es muy directo solo
fijémonos que la f crece como yo quiera
crece muchísimo o sea el detalle es que
no podemos dar un número que podamos
decir que la función siempre va a estar
por debajo de ese número si pudiéramos
darle esta en particular la g pues no
crecería tanto verdad y bueno hay que
tener cuidado porque el logaritmo
natural de x es esencialmente este para
las x más grandes que 10 por ejemplo
ok bueno quizás no no no sea buen
ejemplo eso pero lo que vamos a tener es
esencialmente esto que la función f
crece tanto como queramos tanto como
queramos siempre entonces como crece
muchísimo siempre vamos a poder más bien
nunca vamos a poder acotar la por
cualquier número porque pues porque esto
se basa en finito verdad entonces con
esto podríamos decir que la regla el
inciso d no es cierto
verdad la función crece muy rápido se
tiende a infinito y por lo tanto no
puede ser acotada verdad así que con
esto podemos concluir que b y c son las
únicas posibles respuestas que son
ciertas